[music playing]
WIL WILLIS: Josh,
Ray, congratulations.
You're both one step closer to
the title of "Forged in Fire"
champion and that
check for 10 grand.
When you came here, you
used our tools and equipment
to make your blades.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
where you will have
five days to make
an iconic weapon from history.
Are you ready to see
what that weapon is?
- Yes.
- Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
WIL WILLIS: All right.
The panabas.
OK.
WIL WILLIS: Known as a chopping
tool for both agriculture
and combat, the panabas
earned its place
as a weapon of war in
the southern Philippines
during the 19th century.
Its sharp, forward curved blade
acted like an oversized meat
cleaver and delivered
deep, clean cuts, which
made it ideal for executions.
On the battlefield,
warriors carrying a panabas
would follow behind
the front line
to behead anyone unlucky
enough to have survived
the first wave of attacks.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
See you in five days.
[music playing]
JOSH WESTON: Let's get it lit.
I'm home, I'm prepped, and
I'm ready to build a panabas,
a weird looking blade.
I'm not even sure
how to describe it,
and I've certainly
never built one.
It's always so much fun to
watch it squish in the press.
My plan is to put some of
the fancier elements to it.
[machine whirring]
Ah [bleep].
My press has seized up.
This is one of those
things that could
be a devastating
three-hour fix, and I
have to have this machine.
It's one of those things
that I haven't had
to deal with in about a year.
Of course, as soon
as I come home
to do the final round something
like this has to happen.
I have to fix this, or I may
just lose the entire day.
RAY KIRK: The most challenging
thing today is to get
my blade ready for heat treat.
Ooh!
Watch that torch.
Not bad.
Building the panabas
has been extremely fast.
Got it all tempered, the
handle attached, bark shaped.
This is wet rawhide to keep
everything pretty solid.
And if everything holds
together good we'll put the--
rats.
The rawhide, it broke.
Then I didn't really
have enough to finish it.
So I pulled the threads
out of some paracord
and I made sure that I had
enough to go from one end
to the other.
Ah, who's back in action?
I need to make up for some
lost time from yesterday,
so I'm going to spend
the day forging and just
smoothing out all the bumps.
She's starting to slim out.
Rough grind done.
I plan to test
the edge of my knife
cutting some saplings down.
And I stole my dog's bone
and I'm going to chop
that to see how it works.
[dog whining]
[dramatic music]
Now for the bone chop.
That's my baby.
It performed excellent.
This particular challenge went
exceptionally fast for me.
Now it's time to relax
for a little bit.
I have wood prepped
for my handle,
and I have it epoxied
together, but I
still don't have
anything close to looking
like a finished handle.
But what I'm going to do is
test it to see if it's strong
or not before I
do anything else.
This test is a make or
break moment for me.
If it doesn't pass I've
essentially lost two days.
[dramatic music]
Damn, I like this sword.
DOUG MARCAIDA: This
is the KEAL test
to see what kind of lethal
damage your panabas will do.
I will take your weapon
and deliver slashes
across this pig carcass.
Josh, you're up first.
You ready?
Absolutely.
[dramatic music]
[hacking]
Yes.
DOUG MARCAIDA: OK, Josh.
This is a scary weapon.
It's got a sweet spot in there
that allows for a nice chop,
and of course second chop
cut through the spine,
the ribs, everything.
Your panabas will KEAL.
Good job.
RAY KIRK: Good job.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right, Ray.
It's your turn.
You ready?
You betcha.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
RAY KIRK: I'm thinking, I just
got to do as good as Josh did.
But I loved it when Doug
said "It will KEAL."
That's with two E's.
[dramatic music]
DOUG MARCAIDA: I need
me a cup of coffee, Ray.
You betcha.
In the feel of this,
I can feel the blade
already wanting to chop.
The arc is right where
the sweet spot is.
That allows the blade to cut
cleanly all the way through.
And overall your
panabas will KEAL.
My favorite.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Next
up is strength test.
Dave?
DAVID BAKER: Gentlemen, in 1521
the explorer Magellan landed
on the island of Cebu,
sparking several decades
of conflict between the
Philippines and Spain.
So to test your
panabas I'm going
to strike a Spanish morion twice
with the edge of your weapon.
Now, this is not about what
your weapon does to the helmet,
but what the helmet
does to your weapon.
Josh, you're up.
You ready?
Sure.
DAVID BAKER: OK.
[music playing]
[thunks]
I don't see any wrinkling,
any deformation,
any rolling upon your edge,
which is pretty amazing.
I put some dents in that helmet.
Ray, you ready for this?
Can't hardly wait.
DAVID BAKER: Let's
make it happen.
[music playing]
[thunks]
OK, Ray.
I can see a little
shiny spot here.
It's just that wire
edge feels like it's
kind of tipped just a hair.
It's definitely still sharp.
It's very nice.
It felt good in the hand.
Thank you.
DAVID BAKER: Next up
is the sharpness test.
For that I'll give
you back to Doug.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Bladesmiths,
we know your blades can KEAL.
We know your blades are strong.
But are they still sharp?
To test the edge
retention of your blade,
I will take your panabas
and I will cut the rope.
That will release
the sandbag, which
simulates an oncoming attack.
I will then run the blade
across this and cut it.
Josh, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
[sand spilling]
Yes.
Oh, he died.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Me like the feel.
Feels good in the hand.
Enough to move and maneuver
in close quarter combat.
And overall, your
weapon will cut.
That's all I ever
wanted to hear!
[laughter]
Ray, it's your turn.
You ready?
RAY KIRK: You betcha?
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
[sand spilling]
DOUG MARCAIDA: This is
going to be tough, Ray.
I know it.
I like your blade too.
Your panabas definitely is a
cutter, and it's easy to wield.
Your panabas will cut.
Thank you, sir.
Good job.
WIL WILLIS: Josh and
Ray, I honestly hate
that it's come to
me to be the guy
that has to say these words.
But there can only be
one "Forged in Fire"
champion in this arena.
And that champion is Josh.
Ray, unfortunately your
panabas did not make the cut.
Jason Knight will explain.
JASON KNIGHT: When it comes down
to this type of competition,
sometimes just
the little details
are the game changer, Ray.
Josh had a little bit more
subtleties in his design.
His handle was
octagonally facet,
and he had file
work in the spine.
And those subtle details are
the reason why Josh's blade won.
WIL WILLIS: Ray, please
surrender your weapon.
Buddy.
You got it.
Give me a hug.
[inaudible]
RAY KIRK: Well, I feel great.
I came here not
to prove anything.
I just enjoy the competition.
My knife performed and his knife
performed, so he got the money
and I got the fun.
Josh, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
You're super excited
right now, aren't you?
This is, like--
it just feels so good.
All of you fans, wherever the
hell you came from, I [bleep]
love you guys.
Josephine with her designs that
helped me get through round two
with the handle, thank you.
You made Daddy win.
I am the "Forged
in Fire" champion!
That's what the
[bleep] happened!
Woo!
[bleep] Sorry, Aunt Edie.
[music playing]